il y a environ 10% de gauche et dans la
population mondiale
ce qui est bizarre c'est pourquoi 10%
moitié-moitié deux gauchers et droitiers
sera était logique ou à la limite que
des droitiers ou que des gauchers mais
pourquoi 10%
quand on dit qu'il ya environ 10% de
gauche et c'est une moyenne si on
regarde dans les détails on constate
déjà une disparité selon le sexe environ
12 % des hommes sont gauchers contre
seulement 9% des femmes alors la
différence n'est pas énorme mais réelle
si on regarde les chiffres par pays on
constate aussi des variations par
exemple sur cette carte on a des
estimations du pourcentage de gauche et
dans différents pays d'europe et on voit
que ça varie de plus d'un facteur 2
entre par exemple la russie à 6% et les
pays bas qui sont à plus de 13%
une étude faite dans les années 90 avait
même estimé qu'il n'y avait que 5 % de
gauche et au japon on pourrait penser
que ces différences géographiques
s'explique par la génétique des
populations
mais il ya aussi un très fort effet
culturel on sait que dans la plupart des
cultures et notamment en occident
jusqu'à une période très récente
le fait d'être gaucher était plus ou
moins mal vu et ça se reflète d'ailleurs
beaucoup dans le vocabulaire qu'il
s'agisse du français de l'anglais du
hongrois et c est donc un peu partout
depuis plusieurs siècles
les gauchers ont été contrariés c'est à
dire qu'on les a forcé à utiliser
préférentiellement leur main droite par
exemple pour écrire ça soit très bien
dans les courbes qui donne le
pourcentage de gauche et en fonction de
l'année de naissance
ici on a les résultats d'un sondage fait
aux états unis sur plus d'un million de
personnes et on voit que chez les gens
nés au début du siècle on ne trouve que
3% de gauche et pas parce qu'il y en
avait moins naturellement mais parce
qu'ils ont été beaucoup contrarié à
cette époque une fois pris en compte ces
effectué culturel de discrimination qui
sont toujours vivaces dans certaines
cultures les variations d'un pays à
l'autre semble plus modéré et il
apparaît que le chiffre moyen d'environ
10% de bosscher soit relativement
homogène dans la population mondiale
le fait que l'on ait une main préférée
ce qu'on appelle la préférence manuel
n'a rien de surprenant en soi c'est
assez logique que notre organisme
optimiste son fonctionnement en
concentrant sa dextérité sur une seule
main qu'elle soit à gauche ou droite
mais ce qui est étonnant on l'a dit
c'est ce chiffre de 10%
on aurait très bien pu imaginer que la
préférence manuel soit déterminé de
façon aléatoire pour chacun de nous et
qu'on ait 50 %
tu y es et 50% de gauche et inversement
on aurait pu aussi imaginer que 100 %
des gens soit droitier ou gaucher
après tout c'est ce qui se passe avec
notre anatomie la position de nos
organes et latéralisé de façon identique
dans la population
on a tous le coeur légèrement à gauche
le foie à droite serra c'est la même
disposition pour tout le monde
alors pour être précis pas pour tout le
monde il existe une anomalie rare
appelée site us in versus qui touche
environ une personne sur dix mille et
pour qui le placement des organes est
inversé le coeur à droite le foie à
gauche etc
dans beaucoup de cas cette inversion
complète ne perturbe pas le
fonctionnement normal de l'organisme et
les personnes touchées peuvent très bien
ne pas le savoir d'ailleurs les
découvrir tardivement par exemple à
l'occasion d'un examen médical mais on
l'a dit c'est une personne sur dix mille
1 donc on est très loin des 10% de
gauche et enfin une personne sur dix
mille bas ça veut dire que parmi tous
ceux qui verront cette vidéo peut-être
quelques dizaines d'entre vous ont un
site us in versus et probablement
certains l'ignorent
et là il ya tout le monde qu'à celle de
vérifier pour tenter de comprendre
pourquoi il ya 10% de gauche et on peut
d'abord pensé à un effet génétique
ça ressemble un peu un exemple classique
qu'on voit en cours de bio le rhésus
vous avez sans doute qu'à part votre
groupe sanguin o à b ou ab vous avez
aussi un groupe rhésus soient positifs
soient négatifs par exemple moi je suis
en plus dans la population le rhésus
positif est largement majoritaire chez
les européens on tourne autour de
seulement 15% de rhésus négatif pour 85%
de rhésus positif et là on connaît
l'explication cette différence
le rhésus et principalement déterminé
par un seul gène situé sur le chromosome
numéro un et il existe deux variantes de
ce gène ont dit deux allèles l'allèle
plus hélas les mois sauf qu'on en
possèdent tous deux exemplaires un
provenant de notre mère et l'autre de
notre père si les deux copies qu'on
possède sont identiques
il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté 1 ceux qui ont
deux fois l'aller le plus sont régis
positif deux fois l'allèle - résultats
négatifs facile mais si on a un allèle
plus c'est un allèle - eh bien on sera
rhésus positif quand même
l'allèle positifs l'emportent on dit
qu'il est dominant et c'est ça qui
explique qu'il y ait beaucoup plus de
rhésus positif dans la population que de
rhésus négatif même si les deux allèles
sont presque aussi fréquent l'un que
l'autre
du coup on a très envie de penser que
pour les gauchers ça puisse être pareil
il doit y avoir un gène avec deux
allèles droite et gauche et le droit
serait dominant ce qui expliquerait qui
est plus de droitiers alors c'est séduit
mais ça marche pas pour comprendre
voyons ce qui se passe avec le rhésus 6
2 par an son résultat négatif
forcément ça veut dire que l'un et
l'autre ont deux fois l'allèle moins à
leur descendance ils peuvent donc passer
que des - et tous leurs enfants seront
nécessairement rhésus négatif eh ben
c'est pas du tout ça qui se passe avec
les gauchers si on a deux parents
gaucher et bien leurs enfants ne seront
pas obligatoirement gauche et est même
loin de là voici des chiffres obtenus
dans une étude réalisée sur plus de 60
mille enfants on y lit le pourcentage de
gauche et en fonction du sexe de
l'enfant et du fait que les parents
soient gaucher ou droitier et on voit
notamment que quand les deux parents
sont gauchers et bien un enfant n'a que
20 à 30% de chances d'être gaucher c'est
plus que 10% mais c'est très loin d'être
100% si ça marchait comme le rhésus tous
les enfants de couples gaucher serait
automatiquement gauche et donc on n'est
pas sur un modèle génétique simple de ce
type avec deux allèles dont un qui est
dominant autre élément essentiel c'est
l'étude des vrais jumeaux
si le fait d'être gaucher était purement
génétique mais les vrais jumeaux devrait
avoir toujours la même préférence manuel
et bien non on voit ici les chiffres
d'une étude réalisée sur 3000 paires de
vrais jumeaux et dans plus de 21 % des
cas les deux ne sont pas latéralisé la
même façon malgré le même patrimoine
génétique
c'est à peine moins que ce qu'on aurait
avec des faux jumeaux et ça nous
montrent que le fait d'être droitier ou
gaucher est certes affecté par les
facteurs génétiques mais pas uniquement
d'autres influences entre en ligne de
compte certains auteurs ont d'ailleurs
proposé des modèles mixtes 1 ou par
exemple un gène existerait en deux
variantes l'une prédisposant à être
droitier tandis que l'autre rendrait
notre préférence manuel aléatoire alors
quand on dit aléatoire un ici il faut
plutôt considérer tous les facteurs
autres que génétique c'est-à-dire notre
environnement au sens large
toutes les influences culturelles mais
aussi physique chimie biologique auquel
on est soumis dans votre enfance
d'ailleurs pour corroborer cette idée on
a l'impression que la préférence manuel
ne se fixent qu'assez tardivement un
vers 7 ou 8 ans quand on commence
vraiment à écrire
sauf que grâce à des échographies de
femme enceinte le neuro psychologiques
peter et peur a pu montrer que dès le
stade foetal les futurs bébés avait déjà
tendance à bouger un de leurs deux bras
plus que l'autre et dès la 15e semaine
de gestation il était possible
d'observer des foetus en train de sucer
leur pousse la plupart du temps toujours
du même côté sur un groupe de 274
enfants 250 dessus c'est leur pouce
et seulement 22 leur pouce gauche un peu
moins de 10%
on trouve déjà presque les proportions
qu'on connaît et encore plus fort en
réinterrogeant certains de ces enfants
dix ans plus tard et peur a pu comparer
leurs préférences manuel avec le pouce
qui suçait dans le ventre de leur mère
sur 75 enfants qu'il a pu retrouver 60
succès leur pouce droit dans le ventre
de leur mère et était tous sans
exception devenu droitier et sur les
quinze suçant leur pouce gauche est bien
dit c'était devenu gaucher et 5 droitier
et encore aucun des cinq n'était devenu
un pur droitier et oui parce que je le
précise pas à chaque fois mais la
préférence manuel c'est pas un truc
parfaitement binaire c'est plutôt un
continuum qu'on peut évaluer en
regardant de quelle main les individus
accomplissent toute une série de tâches
usuelles et ici pour ces cinq droitier
dont je vous parlais bien sûr les 9
actions sur lesquelles ils étaient
testés il en faisait quand même toujours
certaines de la main gauche
ils ne sont pas devenus des pur droitier
tout ça laisse penser que dès le ventre
maternel la préférence manuel est déjà
très fortement déterminés et donc à
moins qu'on contraignent les jeunes
enfants
tout est presque déjà joué mais vu qu'on
a dit qu'il n'y avait pas que des effets
génétiques un loin de là ça laisse
envisager que la préférence manuel se
déterminent dans l'utérus de la mère
dans les premiers stades du
développement
on sait d'ailleurs que c'est évidemment
ce qui se passe avec la latéralisation
des organes aux tout premiers stades du
développement embryonnaire
on a des amas de cellules qui semble
symétrique et c'est un gène appelé nodal
qui intervient pour provoquer la
symétrie du développement et induire ce
qui deviendra plus tard la
latéralisation des organes un exam
proche bien qu'un peu différent c'est ce
qui se produit avec les coquilles
d'escargot vous n'avez peut-être jamais
remarqué mais l'immense majorité des
coquilles d'escargot tournent dans le
sens des aiguilles d'une montre
quand on la regarde du dessus mais pour
certains spécimens très rares environ un
escargot sur 20000 pour le petit gris de
bourgogne l'aco qui s'enroule dans
l'autre sens les escargots ont aussi un
gène du type nodal qui déclenche
l'enroulement de leur coquille et on le
sait parce que si on inactifs ce gène
chez un escargot et bien il développera
une coquille droite
en revanche le choix de l'orientation
c'est à dire normal ou inverse n'est pas
déterminé parce ged mais plutôt par des
protéines hérité de sa mère
on peut donc imaginer chez l'humain un
mécanisme analogue pour notre préférence
manuel par exemple il est possible que
le fait qu'on devienne gaucher ou
droitier dépendre en partie de facteurs
génétiques mais se détermine de façon
précoce aux premiers stades de notes de
hautement dans l'environnement intra
utérin alors tout ça est plausible du
point de vue du mécanisme mais vous
remarquerez que ça répond toujours pas à
la question s'était posée au départ à
savoir pourquoi 10% de gaucher et là on
peut tenter de chercher des réponses du
côté de l'évolution
[Musique]
la première chose qui est important de
dire c'est qu'il n'y a pas forcément de
réseau évolutif pour expliquer le fait
qu'ils aient 10% de gauche et il faut se
méfier de cette tendance qui s'appelle
l'adaptation nisme et qui consiste à
penser que tous les traits qu'on observe
sur une espèce sont forcément le
résultat d'un processus de sélection
naturelle et qui doivent donc forcément
procurer un avantage vous permettre une
adaptation à un environnement donné
on sait que ça n'est pas toujours le cas
et un trait comme le fait qu'ils aient
dit pourtant de gauche et dans la
population n'a pas forcément une raison
et évolutive
bon ça n'empêche pas d'en chercher mais
gardons ça en tête si on veut aborder la
question de la préférence manuel sous
l'angle de l'évolution
il faut évidemment regarder ce qu'il en
est des espèces autres que l'être humain
est lâché beaucoup d'espèces on retrouve
une forme de préférence manuel par
exemple chez le chat dont il a été
montré que sur des tâches complexes ils
avaient toujours tendance à utiliser la
même pâte
la différence avec nous c'est que la
répartition est plutôt de 50 50 entre
les chats droitier et les shaks gauche
et le fait qu'ils aient une préférence
d'un côté on l'a dit n'a rien de
surprenant au regard de l'évolution les
organismes ce spécialiste d'un côté pour
optimiser leur fonctionnement
c'est une hypothèse crédible ce qui est
étonnant dans lequel l'humain c'est
vraiment la forte dissymétrie 1 90 10
alors on a bien trouvé chez certains
animaux des répartitions autre que 50 50
entre les droitiers et les gauchers
par exemple chez certaines espèces de
perroquets ou kangourou ou encore chez
les crapauds qui apparemment préfère à
60% donner des coups blanca droite qu'à
gauche
mais rien aussi spectaculaire que chez
l'être humain évidemment là où on a très
envie de regarder pour comprendre
l'évolution de la préférence manuel
c'est chez nos proches cousins les
grands singes car il faut tout d'abord
dire que ce ne sont pas des observations
facile à faire et à quantifier un et les
études sont à prendre avec un peu de
prudence
malgré tout la synthèse la plus complète
publiée en 2011 semblent montrer une
légère préférence à droite chez les
gorilles les chimpanzés et les bonobos
et à gauche chez les orangs outans mais
à nouveau ça reste un effet les g1 très
inférieur à ce qu'on voit chez l'humain
tout ça semble indiquer que la
répartition très asymétriques de la
préférence manuel sera une apparition
relativement récente et qui serait
spécifique de la lignée humaine
alors pour en savoir plus on peut
essayer de remonter à la préhistoire
pour comprendre si nos ancêtres avaient
aussi une préférence manuel comparable à
celle qu'on observe aujourd'hui en
étudiant différentes formes d'art
pariétal des auteurs ont pu conclure
qu'il y à quelques dizaines
milliers d'années il y avait déjà une
forte proportion de droitier chez homo
sapiens et en analysant différents types
d'outils et la manière dont il était
taillée il a été suggéré que cette forte
proportion était déjà présentes il y a
cinq cent mille ans voire 1,5 million
d'années pour l'étude la plus ambitieuse
si le fait d'avoir une préférence manuel
très asymétriques dans la population est
spécifique de l'homme
et bien certains ont eu l'idée d'aller
en chercher l'origine dans une des
caractéristiques qu'on ne partage pas
avec les autres animaux le langage oral
on l'a dit il n'y a pas que notre
préférence manuel qui est latéralisé il
ya aussi notre anatomie et ça se limite
pas au positionnement de nos organes car
ça concerne aussi le fonctionnement de
notre cerveau
une des premières mises en évidence de
l'asymétrie notre cerveau est due aux
neurologues paul broca en 1861 broca
avait un patient atteints d'aphasie
c'est-à-dire incapable de parler ou plus
précisément il savait prononcé qu un
seul mot après la mort de son patient
broca montre par une autopsie que celui
ci souffrait d'une lésion au lobe
frontal gauche des suites d'une syphilis
et il en conclut que cette partie du
cerveau gauche sert à la production du
langage ça a été confirmé de nombreuses
fois depuis et on appelle cette partie
du cerveau l'air de broca autre
caractéristique de notre cerveau le
croisement des voix sensorimotrice alors
ce terme désigne le fait que c'est la
partie gauche du cerveau qui commande
vos membres droit et en interprète les
sensations et inversement
c'est le cerveau droit qui agit sur vos
membres gauche alors petite précision en
passant on entend souvent parler de
cerveau droit cerveau gauche en
psychologie le cerveau gauche très
analytique et rationnelle tandis que le
cerveau droit cearà et créatif intuitif
alors c'est faux vous allez droit de
considérer ça comme une métaphore
intéressante et utile pourquoi pas mais
anatomiquement parlant et bien ça n'est
pas correct dans le cerveau gauche ce
qu'on trouve c'est donc à la fois l'air
de production du langage l'air de broca
et le contrôle moteur des membres droit
et ça ça suggère une hypothèse
intéressante pour expliquer l'abondance
des droitiers on ne se rend pas
forcément compte au quotidien quand on
parle mais la production de langage
nécessite un contrôle musculaire
extrêmement précis songez à tous ces
minuscules mouvements que vous devez
faire avec votre bouche votre langue
pour articuler une phrase
eh bien on peut alors imaginer que
l'évolution est choisi de concentrer ses
ressources de contrôle moteur sur le
cerveau gauche ce qui permet la
production du langage mais donne de fait
un avantage aux membres droit et du coup
les gauchers d'une certaine manière
berne optimiserait pas leurs ressources
cérébrale puisqu'il doit a priori
développé leur cerveau gauche pour
produire le langage et leur cerveau
droit pour contrôler finement leur main
gauche
à moins à moins que les gauchers et le
cerveau à l'envers une sorte de site us
in versus cérébrale alors non pas
exactement mais quand même des
chercheurs ont analysé par irm la
position de l'air de broca chez
différents droitiers et gauchers et ils
ont pu montrer que certains avaient
l'air de broca à droite et ça dépend de
leurs préférences manuel la proportion
va de 3% seulement chez les droitiers a
quand même 25 % chez les gauchers donc
on ne peut pas affirmer brutalement que
les gauchers ont le cerveau à l'envers
mais un quart quand même ont l'air de
broca à droite et d'une façon générale
ils ont un cerveau - latéralisé alors
nouvelle mise en garde un sur ses liens
constatées entre les structures
cérébrales et le comportement
on a quand même un petit problème de
poule et d'oeuf on sait que le cerveau
est capable de modifier son
fonctionnement son organisation ses
connexions c'est ce qu'on appelle la
plasticité cérébrale et du coup est ce
que c'est la position de l'ère du
langage qui influencent le fait qu'on
soit droitier ou gaucher ou à l inverse
est-ce que c'est notre préférence manuel
qui va induire le développement du
langage dans une zone où le contrôle
moteur et plus efficace et on peut
légitimement se poser la question dans
la mesure où on a vu que la préférence
manuel semble se déterminer très tôt
dans le développement de l'embryon
au total si on en revient à la
perspective révolutionnaire on peut
raisonnablement faire l'hypothèse que
les droitiers possède un avantage sur
les gauchers du fait qu'ils optimisent
mieux leurs ressources cérébrale ils ont
mutualisé l'air de broca pour le langage
avec le contrôle moteur de leur main
droite alors testé ce type d' hypothèse
est assez difficile mais si les gauchers
sont vraiment désavantage est une chose
qu'on peut déjà faire c'est regarder si
le fait d'être gaucher donne par exemple
une espérance de vie réduite par rapport
aux droitiers par exemple il ya moins de
gauche et chez les personnes âgées et
très peu chez les centenaires
est ce que c'est parce qu'il meure
plutôt que les droitiers et ben non
c'est très difficile de conclure il ya
un biais énorme dans les analyses de ce
type on l'a dit c'est le fait que
pendant des décennies on a contrarié les
gauchers donc oui chez les centenaires
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas beaucoup de
gauchers mais pas forcément parce que
les gauchers sont morts avant d'avoir
atteint 60 ans est tout simplement parce
qu'on les a beaucoup contrarié à leur
époque
alors malgré tout même en prenant ses
effets en compte il reste une suspicion
que les gauchers est effectivement une
espérance de vie plus courte que les
droitiers il semblerait que ce soit le
cas au moins en temps de guerre pour
lesquels on peut imaginer que les armes
soient moins adaptés aux gauchers et en
ce qui concerne aussi les morts
accidentelles dans un monde fait pour
les droitiers bien les risques sont plus
nombreux pour un gaucher mais c'est un
effet bien trop faible et bien trop
récent pour qu'il puisse avoir joué un
rôle significatif dans la sélection de
seulement 10% de gauche et c'est le même
topo pour une explication qu'on entend
parfois les chevaliers droitier portent
leurs boucliers à gauche et donc aurait
mieux protéger leur coeur que les
gauchers alors pourquoi pas mais là
aussi il s'agit d'un effet très marginal
qui concerne très peu d'individus et qui
est intervenue tardivement dans
l'évolution humaine
en conclusion le fait d'être droitier
pourrait effectivement procurer un
avantage évolutif peut-être lié à
l'optimisation du contrôle moteur et du
coup on peut retourner l'argument si les
droitiers sont avantagés pourquoi est-ce
qu'il subsiste encore environ 10% de
gaucher et ça c'est presque partout dans
le monde
il devrait avoir été anti sélectionnés
et donc supplantés par les droitiers
s'ils sont toujours là bas c'est bien
qu'ils doivent avoir eu aussi un petit
avantage évolutif à mettre dans la
balance n'est en rien un argument qu'on
entend souvent un sujet c'est le fait
que les gauches et serait avantagé dans
les combats et ça se voit très bien dans
les sports où il ya un affrontement
entre deux personnes
le cas le plus connu c'est le tennis
parmi les participants au tournoi du
grand chelem entre 1968 et 2011
il y avait 11 % de gauche et chez les
hommes mais si on garde les vainqueurs
de ces tournois se furent dans 21% des
cas des gauchers presque le double on a
tous en tête des exemples de tennisman
gauchers célèbres mcenroe connors ce
navratilova seles nadal alors petite
précision à un nadal est en fait
complètement droitier et la seule chose
qui fasse de la main gauche bien c'est
tenir sa raquette
selon une explication assez répandu au
tennis ce qui ferait l avantage des
gauchers c'est le fait qu'ils soient
moins nombreux du coup un joueur
droitier est habitué à jouer des
droitiers et quand il rencontre un
gaucher il est déstabilisé il doit
s'adapter alors que pour un gaucher et
ben c'est la norme de rencontrer un
droitier alors au tennis cet avantage
tend à s'estomper ces dernières années
est d'ailleurs chez les femmes il semble
avoir quasi disparu mais dans d'autres
sports c'est encore très vrai en escrime
on dépasse les 30% de gauche et de même
que chez les lanceurs au baseball et
chez les batteurs on atteint 40% de
gauche et alors ce qui est important
c'est que cet avantage les gauchers est
manifeste que dans les sports
d'opposition direct
ça n'est pas que les gauchers serait
plus doué pour le sport en général par
exemple ou golf ou fléchettes
al'avantage n'existe pas alors oui il ya
vraiment quelqu'un qui a regardé ça pour
un article scientifique
bref si les gauchers ont un avantage
lors des affrontements eh ben ça
pourrait expliquer qu'ils aient réussi à
se maintenir un petit seuil de 10 % dans
la population générale
malgré le fait qu'ils soient
désavantagés en général pour le contrôle
moteur et bien sauf que non cet argument
est probablement incorrect à l'échelle
de l'évolution il ya quand même eu en
proportion très très peu de morts à
l'issue d'un affrontement en duel entre
deux individus
si on compare ça à toutes les autres
causes de mortalité donc l'impact de cet
avantage sur les mécanismes de sélection
naturelle est certainement assez
négligeable même en admettant que les
gauchers et un avantage réel à la
bagarre ça n'est probablement pas ça qui
peut expliquer le fait qu'il y en ait
toujours
alors pour tenter de comprendre pourquoi
il reste encore des gauchers il ya plein
d'autres hypothèses évolutionniste qui
ont été avancées par exemple les
gauchers serait plus intelligent plus
beau plus créatifs ils auraient un
meilleur succès en matière de
reproduction etc
mais n'en déplaise aux gauchers rien de
très convaincant n'a été montrée et pour
cause ces hypothèses sont très
difficiles à tester scientifiquement
en conclusion on n'a pas vraiment de
réponse à la question pourquoi y at il
des gauchers et vous remarquerez que
comme souvent en biologie on a essayé de
répondre à cette question de deux façons
différentes
pourquoi peut vouloir dire par quel
mécanisme et on a vu que même si on
comprend pas tout on a des hypothèse
intéressante pour expliquer comment se
détermine la préférence manuel le fait
qu'on devienne droitier ou gaucher
mais en biologie pourquoi peut aussi
vouloir dire pour quelles raisons
évolutive et la barre n'a pas vraiment
de réponse
et comme je l'aï dit plus haut gare à
l'adaptation nisme il n'y a pas
forcément de réponse merci d'avoir suivi
la vidéo si elle vous a plu n'hésitez
pas à partager laïque et facebook
twitter la cloche tout ça ce qu'ils
souhaitent peuvent venir sur kiki et je
vous l'avais aussi aller jeter un coup
d'oeil à mon livre s'appelle insoluble
mais
merci à bientôt
[Musique]